we have our namesake here at the rich
eyes and so mr rich eisen joining us
live
from cleveland ohio omeo omayo
cleveland ohio mr eisen are you there
i am sir how are you ryan everybody i'm
doing
well i'm doing well so you know we're
hearing all the rumors kind of
one-off here and social media and
everything but hey they're on on
on site what what are you hearing uh is
gonna
take place tonight here in those first
10 picks
apparently the only thing that is 100
sure
is trevor lawrence is first overall and
it's going to rain
those are the two things that are one
it's one of those it's not even
it's one of those midwestern slate gray
days where i
don't see i don't you know you can't see
very far in front of the window in front
of you
um but fans are still pouring in and
we're still going to put the jaguars on
the clock and
they built this huge draft hall
right up against lake erie so i'm
already trying to figure out
um you know what what sort of line i
could use
that the pics that don't work out or
they're mistake by the lake
you know right here in ohio um and
we're we're going to go in that draft
hall and all the the draft tables are
set up and
the commission's going to put the
jaguars on the clock at 8 o'clock and
i guess now we need to look out for
somebody who wants to hop into the top
ten
because they think that trey lance
or justin fields is gonna fall and
um the question is how far do you go
to guarantee you get one of them i guess
atlanta would be the furthest you can go
to guarantee you get one of them
and um and then maybe
miami it's six you know with the bengals
at five
be willing to trade out and go so far
down
as to maybe where the saints go how
expensive would that
really be i mean we're talking top five
um
miami i think is interested in trading
out you know i i think miami is
interested in trading out if
uh chase and pitts are not there at six
which could happen if the falcons go
ahead and take
uh pits and the bengals decide to give
the weapon the borough that he had in
college as opposed to protecting him
with penne sewell
and if if that's their choice at six i
think that
i think the dolphins trade out and
that's where somebody could trade in
and potentially have a choice between
lance and fields
um at six so if you're the saints you
want to move into the top ten
how far do you have to go to make sure
you don't move in
for you know wind up with a receiver you
know what i'm saying or
or or how far do you go and and and and
we're all assuming that they're coming
for
for for a quarterback i wouldn't be
surprised if they're coming for pits
you know like that that wouldn't
surprise me either because if you
remember the saints traded up into the
first round of the draft in philly and
we all thought it was for
um a quarterback we thought it was for
deshaun watson
we thought that's where they're coming
to take and and instead they
they went and they took i think that kid
marcus davenport their
defensive lineman so we're all thinking
well they're not happy with jameis and
they're not happy with tayson hills
they're trying to get one of these
quarterbacks
what if it's for pits what if they fall
in love with him just like everybody
else
and a weapon like pits is put in the
hands of sean payton with
can't guard mike and alvin kamara and
jameis winston i mean
you can kind of go to work that way so
um
it's a lot of intrigue and a lot of fun
going on right here right now
yeah diana rossini uh just uh
sent out a message about how they have
they have heard from
everybody the atlanta falcons have and
as of now
they have not heard anything that they
want to move off that spot
and kyle pitts is their guy at four i
think the whole first round really
hinges on what they do in terms of how
far
both fields and trey lance if those are
the two left
fall the rest of the way well i think
you know
our fearless leader who is in your ear
in my year every day john bowie
of our show is a die hard saints fan
would be the first to attest that
very warm place would have to freeze
over for the falcons to trade with the
saints
right and and it would also have to be
like
you know an entire ditka-like draft i
think
um but you never know there are strange
bet fellows as we know
um when we spoke to john harbaugh on
tuesday we asked him hey
you know any thoughts about you know not
taking the best offer available for
orlando brown because it came from the
chiefs a team that you will have to go
through
presumably to win the conference and get
to the super bowl and they said no
they're just taking the best offer
available so
that could be possible i don't know you
know the falcons
if you're atlanta and you have so much
so many holes to fill
why would you trade out of the top ten
you know you'd have to re
you know for i guess for a ton of picks
in the future maybe
but trading out not and and not getting
the quarterback
to start the clock on on um
on matt ryan and or not getting him the
weapon that
can make him a super bowl champion in
the time he has remaining
just to put more picks in the bank
in 2022 and 2023 just
i don't know how that makes a lot of
sense so
i you know what i've said on the show
the guys around you know what you said
on the show
you know it's been for sure pits in my
mind for atlanta
and just rip the knob off and just take
them and not think about it anymore
but um again tonight's just going to be
dynamite and the first domino is san
francisco obviously
they made the big move we're talking to
rich eisen uh who is in
cleveland as we speak live getting ready
to broadcast their
nfl network show tonight for the nfl
draft the 49ers at 3
made the move a month ago a huge splash
really the only team in the top 10 that
you know
has a super bowl pedigree because they
were there just a year ago
uh just over a year ago where do they go
ultimately they've had to know who they
fell in love with
mac jones name was thrown in the mix
it's gently kind of been moved to the
side a little bit in trey lance's name
where do they go tonight at number three
yeah
i like how you use the word gently there
um
you know i i've i've gotten the sense
for the last week
two weeks and again i don't talk to
anybody in that building
um other than you know to invite them on
the show
and they have gently um said no
because there's a lot of sensitivities
going on right now
um and um we'll get them on after the
draft and
try and pry out as much information as
possible about this process
but you know we had trey lance on the
show the other day and you could just
you could just ask the guys that are in
the room there were you how impressed
all of us were
with him and by him and from just his
insatiable desire to learn and get
better
to uh reach out to daniel jeremiah to
pick his brain he said he's picked the
brains of
dozens of people i've i've heard since
getting here that he's he's called like
offensive line coaches in the league
to say you know just to talk concepts
like he's just burning up the phone
lines himself
and how can you not
be impressed by that and i understand
there's tape and i understand that he's
only had 17 career starts and i
understand he didn't play last year and
i understand he's raw and i understand
all of that but just when you look at
the future and you have to actually
you know be a prospect and and and take
a look at this prospect and what he can
blossom into if he's in your care
um i i just can't believe that the
niners and the offense that they have
and the ability to
make you play 11 on 11 if with a
quarterback who can run
why they would just not take him or
justin fields for that matter
but everybody still seems to think the
signs point to mack jones
i guess uh our buddy florio uh who kicks
off our lineup on nbc sports on peacock
every day is tweeting out that the
league has asked the niners to keep
their plans
to themselves don't leak it to somebody
and i'm i'm kind of holding my breath
for that report that you know from ian
or
schefter or somebody that the niners
have chosen this person and that's who
it's gonna be i
i really would love for the commissioner
to take that card to the podium tonight
and the whole country is just you know
holding their breath and we'll find out
who that is and that does
truly inform the rest of the draft and
who will go
to atlanta who will go to cincinnati
potentially may not be affected by it
but after that you know it's on and
who's trading in who's trading up who's
falling out
who does that push down to the top of
the tens and mid teams maybe
for for somebody to just sit and take or
or or or trade out uh i'm
this is great i mean have as many
quarterbacks at the top and so much
intrigue about it
you know uh it's exactly what you want
an nfl draft to be ryan
it it really it almost reminds me of the
possibility
of what they kind of pulled a few years
ago with the chicago bears how john
lynch was able to move
out of the second spot and the bears
step in and take a guy named
mitchell trubisky and it almost feels
like there's a karmic
shift here that what if san francisco
does this huge move
and they've looked like they've done so
well in drafting players and moving
around
to only go to three and draft mac jones
a guy that everybody's like
really underwhelmed with similarly to
what the bears fans felt when mitchell
trubisky was drafted second overall i
don't know if it's a karmic
resurgence here on in terms of that but
yeah i'm with you on this i
i want to not know what's going to
happen
until the commissioner stands up at pick
number three and reads off
uh who it's going to be i think it it
the drama
after last year uh actually being live
you back onto the scene and watching it
all play out in real time i think would
be
unbelievable for drama tonight in the
nfl draft
well i'll tell you what ryan i mean you
kind of just hit on something right
there about
you know matt jones and if he's selected
and the niner fans kind of
scratching their heads the reason why
they'll be left scratching their heads
is because nobody in the nfl
talent evaluation community nobody
in the news and information women and
men community in the nfl
nobody in the you know sec
media was talking about matt jones
being a top five prospect in the nfl
draft
let alone the best player on his team in
alabama
and then all of a sudden kyle shanahan
moves up to three
and if he does take them he has now
basically
kingdom on the back row of the nfl
checkerboard
to say i thought he was a top five
prospect in the nfl
and he is and he's coming here and
thus niner fans have got to trust in
kyle shanahan but if you also
remove all of that from the equation
he is a self-made kid he doesn't have
great athletic ability
or a big huge arm i'll just say this
screw it i'm not saying he's a comp but
was joe montana that touted either you
know i mean
in joe they trust i mean joe can walk on
water up there
if kyle shanahan thinks this is the guy
and he's traded up for him
and also he's an alabama national
champion if you
were taking alabama's quarterback to a
win so damn high last year
why can't matt jones go ahead and be
that and then if you just strip away
what's going to happen for
my beloved jets tonight ryan well i
think about it i i want you to i want
you just to
i love your i love your the the way you
the loyalty you stay with the new york
jets i just well i have no choice
ryan it's in me it's in my blood my
brother put it there years ago at least
i was
smart enough to realize my championships
had to come from somewhere so i
told my brother he could keep the mets
and i took the yankees when chris
there you go against the royals in 1976
so at least i made
that smart decision as a child but with
the jets just look at this
we're all in on zach wilson yes you are
i'm told to be all in on well because
we've been told this
this is what we've been told i said it
many many times on the show i'll say it
one last time before he's
an actual new york jet we didn't watch
and if
new york fans and jet fans had watched a
single second of byu football
they didn't tell any and and we are all
in on him we are all excited we are told
he's an electric personality even though
he hasn't done
any interviews before the draft we are
told that he has got
incredible ability to throw on the run
to throw and anticipate to
to actually run himself but he's got all
of this ability and he's got
he's got a game like aaron rodgers a
game like patrick mahomes we're hearing
all this and we are all
the way in but if you had told us
this point last year that we would be
number two overall just missing out on
trevor lawrence
and we're gonna put our hopes in the kid
who was
broken and battered broken and battered
wasn't even named a team captain for byu
football
and we were gonna take the kid who went
on a magical run for byu football
and ditch sam darnold for him
we would be freaking out over it
freaking out and i can already see
brockman across the way from you smiling
because he knows it he knows it he gets
it he's in the afc
east waterskiing behind all those yachts
behind 19 rings or whatever the hell
belichick calls his boat
as he as he as he pulls the water skiing
patriots fans and through that wake with
brady for 20 years
we're hoping that that kid tonight
is our brady arma homes our rogers our
russell wilson i could keep going on and
on
but last year if you had told us this is
the kid you're going to put your hopes
and wishes in
second overall in the 2021 draft we
would be going
nuts it's just what we all believe is a
fan base we have no control over it we
just have to trust the brass
niners fans are going to go maybe a
little wobbly if it's matt jones tonight
and jet fans we are all the way in well
you know
that's that's the way it's that's the
way it works
for all of us crazy ass fans well i i
didn't mean to kind of
dampen the mood uh talking about the
jets a little bit this is the way i talk
ryan
i'll tell you this you want to talk
about dampening the mood
hey hey brockman did you see who um dj
uh had the patriots taking the mock
draft last night did you see that
it's trey lance right yeah yeah trading
up
to 11 to take trey lance oh yeah and i
pointed out on the air
fans will have nine picks to celebrate
the zack wilson
[Laughter]
nine picks because the minute belichick
trades up to take trey lane
if that happens oh baby then you've got
two
rookie quarterbacks attached to the hip
the patriots starting the one the jets
didn't choose
could you imagine what that rivalry
would be like
twice a year if that happens
oh just buckle up yeah it would be
insane for about five minutes because
systemically and you've been a part of
this tonight may be the last time we've
well actually i've ever heard of zach
wilson i'm just saying
this ends tonight ryan
tonight he is the savior
it happens tonight yes i am not
thinking anything else good for you
that's what a true fan should be like
have the football gods finally smile
upon them
tonight in the cleveland range i think
it's about time something goes your way
rich i really do so hopefully that is
the case
tonight uh and with that yes we're going
to send you on your way to do your job
thank you my friend for always
supporting me and giving me an
opportunity
to be a part of this this is so much fun
when i get to do it tomorrow we'll
talk tomorrow after we have a great time
tonight have a great time buddy have a
great show all right
thanks bye that's our fearless leader
rich eisen hey you watched all the way
to the end
thanks for that watch more right here